so amadeo goes in
he goes in hard and fast like a prison
rape
they try and grab they they try and grab
the the congo
they arrest his guys he has to negotiate
to get the guys out the cia's involved
it's it's a whole thing he threatens to
he oh he hires this this whole he hires
a bunch of um mercenaries to basically
fly in and rescue the troops he doesn't
have to do it
but he does actually hire them and
they're waiting to go in
so while this did i tell you that most
of his this i love this
most of the meetings that he has like to
arrange these types of things like he
has a bunch of meetings with some people
from uh
is it to tajikistan because he also
tries
a coup in tajikistan they they have
their meetings like at
at disney world mm-hmm and it's just
perfect like the whole thing takes place
in orlando
that's perfect i mean it's so it's so
fitting
for somebody who thinks he's going to
take over the world so it is after
after they get the guys back they then
he's also trying to he
also is approached by some uh
oligarchies
who want to take over to jerkistan
because they're having an issue with
putin
um and he's basically they're trying to
get him to
to to pull off a coup and to jerk
to tajikistan tajikistan
so that's happening and then so the
other thing is okay so look once he gets
the guys back
right so he gives him how does he get
him back well i mean they basically let
him go like there's just so much
pressure on them and they're
you know they're and what is it they do
that to try to like derail him
yeah absolutely because his guy now ends
up taking like he ends up
running uh or he ends up coming in like
fifth and the guy was like third and he
may end up have
having one but now you just you just
basically just decimated his entire
campaign
we just took 32 of your congo guys so
these guys are basically like okay we're
done
yeah these guys will basically just grab
us and shoot us in the [ __ ] street
yeah so i you know i like you i want you
to be president
it's not worth me dying yeah so
so been real his guy ends up getting
i think comes in fifth amedeo
amadeo ends up being invited to the
white house
i've got pictures of him that's
president bush have you seen the picture
of him with president bush
um and not like it's not like a photo op
i mean he's in
he's in the roosevelt room with people
from nato
and they're all sitting there talking
and you know this is not a photo easy to
think he made it to the white house the
white house he's standing there with
those people
and this guy is trying to take over the
whole [ __ ] world and
you know what's so funny is but think
about if you had a buddy who said that
everybody that's in politics somewhat
think don't you think everybody in
politics is kind of like him not to that
extreme
there everybody's got a little the
foundation
of that way of thinking
i feel like is in some way or another
in the people's minds that are in
politics what that they ultimately want
to take over the world nothing
like i'm not saying to that extreme
extent but like a watered-down version
of that
i mean yeah i think they all think that
they may all think that they want to
make some
some massive changes and but keep in
mind he's
his he's trying to dominate he's off the
rails i mean in the world
yeah he's trying to he's thinking look
we're
going to do it economically or i'm going
to do it with force
but it's going to happen and he's
actively look if you gave me 200 million
dollars
i'm still never going to think i can't i
can't in the world know i can start
well yeah i got i can start invading
countries now it's not gonna
i'm gonna go buy some planes i'm going
to get these guys over here we're going
to do it
it's never even going to enter my mind
this is the other thing that kills me
about him
somebody so he's got him a lot of money
he's got hunt not not
hundreds of millions of dollars you gave
me a hundred million dollars i'm going
to have
i'm going to have a a penthouse filled
with strippers
i'm driving a couple ferraris and maybe
a a porsche and a lambo
this guy doesn't do anything he's
driving like a like a a five-year-old
mercedes
is that what you would do with 100
that's a goddamn
how many how much money would you spend
on the hair one more i just need one
more surgery seven grand that's all you
need
seven grams nothing seven stacks ain't
not seven racks
we could probably get that in the chat
only worse can we get seven racks in the
chat
for matt cox's hairline
racks in the chat racks in the chat he
then ends up so here's where it goes
wrong
rats in the chat he ends up he ends up
sponsoring the nato summit
in latvia riga no and riga latvia what
am i saying enrique latvia
i don't know why you're looking at me i
have no idea listen i was i was i mean i
was educated in the south i don't know
i didn't know there was actually i
didn't i don't know there was is that
russian
i don't know no [ __ ] idea okay the
point is is that he ends up sponsoring
the
the summit part of the summit he
sponsors some of it while he's there he
ends up going to a cocktail party
uh he actually meets with with the cia
too but he
it's it's too much to get into at a
cocktail party he ends up having a manic
moment that [ __ ] hits right hmm that oh
yeah
he ends up he ends up having a manic
moment where he ends up telling
a bunch of people at a cocktail party
they ask him about the congo
and what his plans were for africa and
he basically tells them
he's going to build like a million man
army and he's going to
take over all of africa and eventually
the entire world and then he says we
won't need nato anymore
so by the time he actually flies back
to the united states they're serving
subpoenas on his
companies they're digging in it takes
about a year or so for them to finally
come up with something they can charge
him with
he won't he won't take a plea he says i
haven't done anything wrong i had
absolute
i had the right to use those funds
because they realize he's now
he's using funds that were held for the
irs he's saying i'm allowed to use those
funds
and and we can argue that out in court
what ends up happening is
the u.s attorney and his gets together
with his lawyer and they get him
um they get him ruled
as a um as a ward of the state and he
becomes
he's uh he's basically he's incompetent
and they they grant him
they give him a guardian they then send
him to
a psychiatric hospital where he's
drugged
and when he comes back they convince him
to sign a plea
a plea and they say look you're going to
sign an open what's called an open plea
you're going to plead to the charges but
we're going to allow you to go in front
of the judge and explain the situation
you'll probably
you might get probation or a couple of
years you'll be fine he's completely
drugged out of his mind
what kind of drugs is he on listen if
you read the transcripts of what he was
on yeah i mean it just goes on and on
and on about that you know
depakote and all kinds of just
ridiculous do you give him any
psychedelics
i don't know about psychedelic like any
kind of like asset or anything how would
i know i don't i don't know anything
about drugs
they wouldn't enlisted it in there i
mean you would have seen it if you would
write no i don't remember the name of
all the drugs people acid what are you
talking about
charles manson i don't i'm sure he was
giving himself
acid he was getting himself most of it
what no the cia was giving him acid bro
i'm sure he tells it how was the cia
don't know about that
hey ultra you bro what are you doing no
that and that's charles manson
wait until you see the [ __ ] podcast
i'm doing next week with this dude who
wrote a book about that you don't know
what's that about
me the cia it was a program that they
were giving yeah i've never heard that
weren't they giving weren't they giving
prisoners was it prisoners or military
or was it the military was both probably
it was the c i'm pretty sure it was the
cia how do you just give somebody acid
they were dosing they were prisoners
yeah they were trying they were doing
mind control [ __ ] that they were testing
on prisoners
to use with military people to basically
convince somebody just to go kill
somebody and like completely drain them
of all emotions and all empathy and
everything
see if they alright he's on three
thousand
milligrams daily eight grams
of um geodone
daily and uh okay leba
levital libtard
whatever daily two milligrams of a
sleep induced agent which helps
accelerate the medication
which is uh razzamore or uh
mature full of bro i can't even say that
this is all the stuff he's on
he said he's basically special yeah it
sounds right
sounds like a goddamn golden corral of
cocktails
so anyway he ends up the judge
he talks so then they take him off the
medication they never tell us they never
tell his guardian
they have him sign a plea here sign the
plea you'll get to go in front of the
judge you can explain what happened
the judge will you know you probably
won't be in trouble it's not a big deal
but you did break the law
sign the plea so he signs a plea what
you're you're a war of the state
you're you're you're in a you're you're
incompetent you were given
they know he was given a guardian why
are you asking me to
sign a plea i'm not allowed to sign a
plea you know i'm not allowed to find a
plea they never tell the guardian
you know when the guardian finds out
that he signed a plea and was found
guilty and sentenced to prison he calls
him from prison
two weeks after he gets there and the
guy's like okay well hey frank i'm glad
you're doing what's and he
he's like well let me know when the
trial is he's like when the trial is
what are you talking about i've been
sentenced
i'm in prison i got 22 years so he goes
in front of the judge they take him off
the medication
and they say go on in there and explain
what you were doing frank he goes in
there and starts talking about world
domination and all this crazy [ __ ]
they just said three days later the
judge is like look
you're done boom 22 years
so